RESISTANCE.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AFTER SPENDING A FEW PRECIOUS
HOURS WATCHING THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TESTIFY TODAY BEFORE THE
HOUSE BUDGET COMMITTEE, I
THOUGHT ONE THING.
WHY ON EARTH DID BILL BARR
VOLUNTEER FOR THIS TYPE OF
ABUSE?
LEAVING THE COMFORT OF HIS
RETIREMENT JUST TO HAVE TO
ANSWER TO SOME OF THE NASTIEST
PEOPLE ON THE FACE OF THE
PLANET?
HE BADGERED BARR ON HIS SYNOPSIS
ON THE MUELLER REPORT.
>> ALL WE HAVE IS YOUR FOUR-PAGE
SUMMARY WHICH SEEMS TO CHERRY
PICK FROM THE REPORT TO DRAW THE
MOST FAVORABLE CONCLUSION
POSSIBLE FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
MAKE DEFINITIVE CONCLUSIONS.
>> LAURA: A KNEE-JERK LIBERAL?
>> YOUR CONCLUSION IS SOMETHING
WE'VE SEEN BEFORE.
IN JUNE 2018, YOU WROTE A MEMO
AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN AND A
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, LAYING
OUT THE PRESIDENT'S CASE AGAINST
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
YOUR ADDITION CLEARLY WENT WELL.
>> Laura: YOUR ADDITION CLEARLY
WENT WELL.
WOULDN'T YOU JUST LOVE TO READ
BILL BARR'S SUBLIMINAL THOUGHTS
ABOUT THAT ENTIRE CHARADE?
I WOULD PAY BIG MONEY FOR THAT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL DIDN'T NEED
THIS.
HE ALREADY WAS ATTORNEY GENERAL,
DON'T FORGET, ALMOST 30 YEARS
AGO WHEN HE WAS A LOT YOUNGER
AND PROBABLY HAD MORE PATIENCE.
LIKE SO MANY OTHERS IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ALL LEFT
THEIR VERY COMFORTABLE LIVES AND
MOVED TO WASHINGTON TO HELP
SOLVE PROBLEMS AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
THAT'S WHAT CIVIL SERVICE IS
SUPPOSED TO BE ALL ABOUT, ISN'T
IT?
BUT THIS IS WHAT THEY DEAL WITH
INSTEAD.
LIKE ALEX AT A RECENT SENATE
HEARING ABOUT THE DETENTION OF
ALIEN KIDS.
>> WE ARE GETTING 300 TO 350
UNACCOMPANIED CROSSING THE
BORDER EVERY SINGLE DAY RIGHT
NOW.
THESE ARE 10, 12, 13,
15-YEAR-OLD KIDS.
THEY'RE COMING ACROSS THE BORDER
BY THEMSELVES.
>> WHAT IS THE CAPACITY OF THE
CHILD PRISON SYSTEM THAT YOU'RE
SEEKING WITH THIS MONEY?
>> YOU KEEP SAYING PRISON
SYSTEM.
IF YOU HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH, PLEASE TELL US.
>> LET ME EXPLAIN IT TO YOU.
>> Laura: I LOVED IT.
THAT'S WHAT EVERY CABINET
SECRETARY SHOULD DO IN THESE
HEARINGS, TURN THE TABLES ON
THESE PEOPLE.
>> IF CHILD DETENTION OR
SEPARATIONS ARE SO OFFENSIVE,
HEY, WHY DON'T YOU CHANGE THE
LAWS?
BETTER YET, SEAL UP THE BORDER
AND END THIS TRAVESTY
ALTOGETHER.
NOW OF COURSE, CONGRESS DOES
HAVE LEGITIMATE CONSTITUTIONAL
OBLIGATIONS TO DO PROPER
OVERSIGHT OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH.
I'M ALL FOR IT.
BUT WHAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
DOING ISN'T OVERSIGHT.
IT'S CHARACTER ASSASSINATION,
EITHER OF THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF
OR ANYONE WHO WORKS FOR HIM.
LOOK AT WHAT THE JACKALS DID
TODAY.
GET THIS.
WE HAVE A CATEGORIZE ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER AND ALL MA
SOUTHERN BORDER AND ALL SHE
CARES ABOUT IS TAXES.
>> AS I SAID BEFORE, WE WILL
FOLLOW THE LAW.
>> YOU'RE NOT AFRAID THAT YOU
WILL BE FILED IF IN FACT YOU
RELEASE THE RETURNS?
>> I'M NOT AFRAID OF BEING FIRED
AT ALL.
I SAID WE WILL FOLLOW THE LAW.
>> I'M VERY PLEASED YOU'RE NOT
AFRAID OF BEING FIRED.
>> Laura: SHE WENT BACK TO HER
FAVORITE CATEGORY.
I'LL TAKE RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS FOR
500.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE I EVER MET A
RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
>> SO YOU NEVER HAD ANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH MR. VICTOR OR
ANYBODY ABOUT SANCTIONS, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
I'VE NEVER MET EITHER OF THEM.
>> NO, NO, NOT MET, BUT HAD A
CONVERSATION PERIOD.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD ANY
CONVERSATION WITH EITHER OF
THEM.
>> OKAY, LET US CONTINUE.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM NORTH
CAROLINA IS RECOGNIZED FOR FIVE
MINUTES.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THAT WENT
ON LONGER THERE.
SHE IS JUST A COMPLETE AND UTTER
EMBARRASSMENT, ALONG WITH
PELOSI, THE CO-RULE
PELOSI, THE CO-RUING QUEEN OF
THE RESISTANCE.
HOW IS ANY OF THIS HELPING THEIR
CONSTITUENTS?
THE ANSWER IS IT'S NOT.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE ALSO CALLED
THE GOP.
I'M THINKING DEMOCRATS SHOULD BE
CALLED JUST UP, AS IN THE
UNSERIOUS PARTY, BECAUSE FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR, THE TRUMP TEAM
UNDERTOOK THE PAINSTAKING
PROCESS OF DOING THINGS LIKE
RENEGOTIATING NAFTA.
CANADA AND MEXICO BOTH SIGNED
OFF ON IT.
SO WHY HASN'T NANCY PELOSI
CALLED IT UP FOR A VOTE?
BECAUSE SHE'S UNSERIOUS.
SHE'S PARROTING BOGUS CONCERNS
OF HER BUDDIES OVER THERE ABOUT
LABOR LAWS AND MEXICO.
>> IT'S A BIG ISSUE HOW PEOPLE
ARE -- WORKERS ARE TREATED IN
MEXICO.
AND TO LIFT UP OUR OWN WORKERS,
YOU DON'T DO THAT BY SUPPRESSING
WORKERS IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT'S AN EXPLOITATION ON BOTH
SIDES.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
WAS.
SHE AND BETO SHOULD GET
TOGETHER.
I HAVEN'T HEARD PELOSI DEMAND
THE SAME FROM CHINA.
THE TRUTH IS PELOSI WANTS TO
THROW SAND IN TRUMP'S GEARS
EVERY CHANCE SHE GETS.
IF OBAMA HAD DOESH
IF OBAMA HAD NEESH
IF OBAMA HAD NEGOH
IF OBAMA HAD NEGOTIATED THE SAME
DEAL, SHE WOULD BE ALL FOR IT.
SAME SCENARIO IS THAT PLAY WITH
THE ONGOING INVASION ACROSS OUR
SOUTHERN BORDERS.
ESTIMATES ARE THAT THIS WEEK
ALONE, WE COULD SEE 150,000
MIGRANTS OVERWHELMING OUR
BORDERS.
DEMOCRATS JUST USE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO GRAND STAND FOR
THE CAMERAS.
>> HOMELAND SECURITY IS
DEFENDING INTO CHAOS A MAJOR
MASSIVE --
>> CONGRESS MUST EXERCISE ITS
DUTY TO PROVIDE A CHECK ON THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
>> YOU PRETTY MUCH HAVE TO BE A
YES PERSON.
OTHERWISE, YOU DO NOT LAST LONG.
>> NEILSON WILL BE KNOWN FOR
IMPLEMENTING A COOL POLICY.
>> LAURA: IT'S SO BAD THAT
CABINET SECRETARIES GET BERATED
ABOUT POLICIES TOTALLY OUT OF
THEIR AREA OF RESPONSIBILITY
EVEN.
>> I'M DISMAYED TO HEAR THAT
YOU'RE WILLING TO DRIVE OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM OFF THE CLIFF
WITH NO PLAN FOR REPLACING IT.
>> WE TAKE LEGAL POSITIONS IN
CASES.
>> Laura: HOW BARR REMAINED AS
COOL AS A CUCUMBER IS BEYOND ME.
EVEN AS THE HEARING WAS ENDING,
THE CHAIRMAN COULDN'T GET THE
CON  --
>> IT'S VERY TROUBLESOME TO SEE
A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AGAINST THE
LAW OF THE LAND.
WE LEAN ON YOU TO COME THROUGH
FOR THIS COUNTRY.
AND WHEN WE SEE YOU TAKING SIDES
AGAINST THE LAW OF THE LAND,
TAKING SIDES THAT YOU MAY NOT
THINK IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, IT TROUBLES
US.
NEVERTHELESS, WE WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY.
>> LAURA: YEAH, WE ALL SHOULD BE
THANKING BILL BARR AND THE
ENTIRE TRUMP TEAM.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAS
STILL MANAGED TO ACCOMPLISH AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
MINDFUL PERSISTENCE VERSUS